sur france 2
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi jean
paul bolufer directeur de cabinet de
christine boutin démissionne mais ne
veut pas déménager
hier la presse avait révélé qu'il
bénéficiait d'un logement public à bas
prix il dénonce une chasse à l'homme
l'europe sans frontières s'élargit à
l'est et au nord neuf nouveaux pays
rejoigne l'espace schengen où la
circulation est totalement libre un
espace qui compte maintenant 400
millions de citoyens
nicolas sarkozy en visite au vatican il
a été reçu par benoît 16 et souhaite que
la france assume et valorise ses racines
chrétiennes la loi chatel a été adoptée
à l'assemblée nationale pour tenter de
faire baisser les prix dans la grande
distribution
elle ouvre aussi une nouvelle brèche
pour le travail du dimanche
enfin au tchad c'est demain que commence
le procès des six français de l'arche de
zoé
le président de l'association eric
breteau parle de mascarade
ses avocats espèrent un règlement
politique révélé hier la sphère avait
pris valeur de symbole en pleine
polémique sur les problèmes
d'hébergement
jean paul bolufer directeur de cabinet
de christine boutin a donc remis sa
démission ce matin après avoir été
épinglée vous le savez pour son logement
à loyer modéré il reconnaît que sa
situation peut choquer mais appelle à
une remise à plat du système
olivet caroff chloé cormery un coup de
téléphone hier soir une entrevue ce
matin avec son ministre en moins de 24
heures jean-paul bolufer a été acculé à
la démission
il accepte dit il le rôle de fusible
moi je souhaiterais que les donneurs de
leçons balaye d'abord devant leur porte
en ce qui me concerne j'ai donné ma
démission de façon totalement volontaire
au ministère du logement christine
boutin a vite fait connaître le nom de
son successeur
elle affirme avoir ignoré jusqu'à hier
les conditions de logement de son
principal collaborateur ces décisions là
sont toujours très très difficile à
prendre un événement c'est
moi j'avais un excellent collaborateur
maintenant le reste
maxi appartement mini loyer les
révélations du canard enchaîné ont fait
mouche dès la mi journée
jean paul bolufer tente une contre
attaque je voudrais tout d'abord posé
une question au maire de paris par votre
intermédiaire et lui demander s'il est
disposé de publier la liste de
l'ensemble des appartements gérés par
cette société de leur superficie de leur
localisation et de leur loyer et de
leurs locataires éventuellement demande
aussitôt rejetée par la mairie de paris
ça prouve bien que tout l'ordre que nous
avons mis à paris depuis sept ans et la
fin de toutes ces pratiques absolument
abominable et bien c'est toujours dans
la culture de certains
l'ex directeur de cabinet n'envisage pas
de quitter son logement
la ville de paris a déclenché une
procédure en ce sens alors ce n'est pas
la première fois que des élus ou des
hauts fonctionnaires sont mises en cause
dans des affaires d'appartements
avantageux qui est concerné comment
fonctionne la régie immobilière de la
ville de paris qui est aujourd'hui
montré du doigt enquête franck génaudeau
pascal caron avec son mini loyer
l'appartement de jean paul bolufer vient
s'ajouter à la liste des scandales liés
au logement géré par la ville de paris
il y eut par exemple la sphère tiberi en
1995 le maire de l'époque avait installé
ses enfants dans des hlm de la ville
alors qu'ils étaient propriétaires
d'immeubles qu'il louait à des tiers
quelques mois plus tard c'est au premier
ministre de l'époque alain juppé de
déménager en catastrophe lui aussi
bénéficié d'un logement à loyer très
avantageux fournis par la ville jean
paul bolufer loue son appartement à la
régie immobilière de la ville de paris
cet organisme gère 58 mille logements
des hlm des logements sociaux
intermédiaires et des logements à loyer
libre sans conditions de revenus
parmi ces logements à loyers libres 250
à 300 appartements de grand standing pas
tous très bon marché on y retrouve des
hauts fonctionnaires des personnalités
politiques des chefs d'entreprises ou
des avocats directeur de cabinet
secrétaires généraux
toi au maire et ses fils jedir fils
d'archevêque c'est à dire les fils de
tout c est lui aussi qui avait des
logements à prix imbattables au
détriment de gens y en avait vraiment
besoin des abus qui concerne également
les hlm selon les associations de
propriétaires
je restaure place et considère qu'une
fois qu'ils ont eu à l'ofj une fois qu'à
logement public leur a été attribué cet
avis et ça ça n'est pas normal
une loi devrait prochainement imposer un
meilleur contrôle en réexaminant la
situation des locataires tous les trois
ans pour éviter les fraudes
toujours à propos de logements on a
appris en fin de matinée qu'un sans abri
et est mort la nuit dernière sur la
prestigieuse place de la concorde à
paris
il dormait sur une paillette une palette
de bois sans couverture et a été
découvert ce matin par des employés des
parcs et jardins images signées bernie
mériaux des postes douaniers fermé des
barrières devenus inutiles je vous le
disais en titre l'europe sans frontières
s'élargit à nouveau neuf nouveaux pays
principalement issus de l'ancien bloc
communiste rejoignent l'espace schengen
où la circulation est complètement libre
c'est un nouveau signe de la
réunification du vieux continent
françois beaudonnet six dames choix de
l'europe
enfin réunis ici à la limite de
l'autriche et de la slovaquie
il y à quelques heures les dirigeants
des deux pays ont symboliquement détruit
leurs frontières
des cérémonies comme celle ci il sent
déroulera partout du nord au sud du
continent
car à minuit les frontières intérieures
qui séparait encore l'europe de l'ouest
des ex pays de l'est vont disparaître
avec neuf pays en plus dans l'espace
schengen 400 millions d'européens vont
donc pouvoir voyager sans passeport avec
une simple carte d'identité
ce matin par exemple les slovaques se
réjouissait déjà les mêmes en irak en
donner personne ne contrôlera ce sera
bien c'est super c'est on va enfin
pouvoir voyager sans passeport et on va
pouvoir traverser toute l'europe
moi je dis merci pour l'ouverture des
frontières merci pour la liberté de
mouvement
il aura donc fallu moins de 20 ans
depuis la disparition du rideau de fer
pour que l'europe présente de nouveau un
seul visage mais cette nouvelle
réunification fait peur trafics en tous
genres immigration clandestine
ces dernières années l'europe a dû
investir des centaines de millions
d'euros pour sécuriser ses nouvelles
frontières extérieures avec la russie
l'ukraine où le bélarus la pologne est
dorénavant particulièrement exposés on
un signal et si quelqu'un traverse du
côté ukrainien on est tout de suite
prévenu grâce à nos caméras thermiques
visière 24 pays font donc maintenant
partie de l'espace schengen
prochaine étape l'entrée de la roumanie
et de la bulgarie en 2011
et c'est dans ce contexte d'une europe
élargie que se met en place peu à peu la
politique de l'immigration choisie
en clair la france qui manque de main
d'oeuvre dans certains secteurs est en
train de définir des quotas métier par
métier même si le mot n'est pas toujours
prononcée c'est une approche
controversée
voici les arguments des uns et des
autres quotas le débat avec vincent
fichman et eric de l'agneau depuis dix
ans le mouvement est incessant 3%
croissant chaque année le secteur du
bâtiment se porte bien
effet direct honni en bouche beaucoup de
monde 120000 personnes cette année
problème les candidats sont difficiles à
trouver
avoir une main d'oeuvre adapté il faut
l'a formé
si on n'a pas ce qu'il faut chez nous
mais on sera bien obligé de s'adresser à
l'extérieur pour combler la pénurie ici
et dans d'autres secteurs
le gouvernement veut sélectionner les
immigrés en fonction de leurs
compétences et avant leur arrivée en
france alors une politique de quotas est
elle nécessaire
on s'aperçoit que les migrants lorsqu'il
entre en france s'intègre beaucoup mieux
quand ils ont un travail donc ils
peuvent accéder à un logement et la
l'immigration peut être une réussite
pour être profitable pour tout le monde
sassou tant d'idées que finalement les
européens même s'ils sont peu qualifiées
vont bien s'intégrer entre guillemets
tandis que pour les non-européens il
faut vraiment qu'il soit très qualifiés
pour qu'ils puissent s'intégrer donc
c'est gênant d'un point de vue de la
sélection 10 ans a peut être nick que
star suppose car deux listes de métiers
existent l'une pour les européens peu de
compétences ont requis deuxième liste
informaticiens géomètre pour les autres
candidats à l'immigration
la france exige des diplômes prendre le
meilleur à l'étranger cela pourrait
revenir à priver cpdh une chance de se
développer une question de morale d'où
une interrogation quelle politique
garantir à leur retour
est ce que l'on veut faciliter c'est une
immigration de mobilité d'allers-retours
une immigration temporaire de personnes
qualifiées qui viendront quelques années
pour se former pour obtenir une
expérience en france et qui retourneront
ensuite dans leur pays
ça fait 30 ans qu'on a échoué sur les
politiques de retour
donc faut pas trop attendre des
en allemagne une politique de quota a
été mise en place dès 2000 ce fut un
quasi échec les diplômés étrangers ont
préféré aller dans d'autres pays
la visite de nicolas sarkozy au vatican
pendant la campagne électorale ils
avaient souvent mise en avant sa foi
catholique
reçu par le pape benoît 16 le président
de la république a rendu un hommage
appuyé aux religions elles ne sont pas
un danger plutôt un atout dit il
sur place à rome alexandre kara stéphane
guillemot ces quelques pas de benoît 16
pour accueillir nicolas sarkozy sur le
signe dans le protocole du vatican d'un
accueil particulièrement chaleureux dans
la délégation française aux côtés du
président un visage inattendu je crois
croyant je prie bonne dizaine de fois
par jour avant de jouer à rome nicolas
sarkozy est venu aussi prendre son titre
de chanoine de saint jean de latran un
titre attribué au chef de l'état
français depuis henri iv
phase 1 des classements développer face
aux bouleversements que connaissent nos
sociétés nous avons besoin de la
contribution de l'église calcul croiser
le fil et la tient profondément un
président en croyant mais deux fois
divorcée pas question pour le vatican
d'aborder le sujet je ne suis pas là
pour faire des commentaires de ce genre
vous en avez suffisamment chez vous ici
c'est tout à fait déplacée et pourtant
dans la délégation une présence discrète
la mère de la chanteuse carla bruni ce
soir la politique européenne reprend ses
droits
nicolas sarkozy dîne avec romano prodi
héros c'est luis zapatero pour évoquer
son projet d'union méditerranée et les
discussions avec benoit 16 on peut être
porté sur le travail du dimanche que
l'église ne voit pas d'un bon oeil la
leur à l'assemblée la loi chatel a été
adoptée elle ouvre une nouvelle brèche
dans le repos dominical pour les
salariés des magasins d'ameublement
mais son objet principal concerne les
fameuses marges arrière dans les grandes
surfaces
après la loi galland et la loi dutreil
c'est un nouveau dispositif pour tenter
de tirer les prix à la baisse
explication valérie le rouge dominique
bonnet démonstration au rayon lessive
prenons ce baril tous les hypermarchés
l'achète au fabricant au même prix par
exemple 10 euros la loi interdit de
négocier détaille alors pour payer moins
cher les grandes surfaces facture des
services par exemple une meilleure
présentation en rayon ou une pub en
catalogue avantage facturée 3 euros au
fabricant
c'est ce qu'on appelle la marge arrière
au final le supermarché ne paye donc que
cet euro sa lessive
il n'avait pas le droit de répercuter la
totalité de cette ristourne sur le prix
en rayon avec la loi chatel ce sera
désormais possible à partir du 1er
janvier je pourrais vendre ce baril de
lessive à prix coûtant donc ça veut dire
qu aura plus d'opérations
promotionnelles
mais les prix vont pas baisser pour
autant et ça c'est ce que le ministre se
garde bien de dire parce que comme les
tarifs industriels augmentent mais
opération de promotion ne vont jamais
compenser l'ampleur des hausses
industrielle avec la loi chatel donc
plus de produits en promo mais le
montant du caddie ne devrait pas changer
le très probable qu'on assiste à une
guerre des prix pas extrêmement forte
mais une guerre des prix sur les grandes
marques
donc ce qu'ils ont donné à un côté
certainement qu'ils vont le reprendre
d'un autre côté sur des produits moins
emblématique pour faire baisser
sensiblement les prix les hypermarchés
demandent à pouvoir marchander avec
leurs fournisseurs
le gouvernement l'envisagent pour le
printemps 2008 et toujours à propos de
consommation on dit souvent que c'est un
moyen de faire de bonnes affaires le
commerce en ligne fait de plus en plus
d'adeptes
mais plusieurs dossiers récents en mise
en lumière également des abus voire des
arnaques
comment s'y retrouver quels sont les
pièges enquête l'ugb aziza lionel
langlade
nous voici dans un entrepôt tenu secret
d'ici partent toutes les commandes de
crue petits ou grands effectués sur le
plus grand site de vente en ligne de
vins le prix en moyenne 15% moins cher
que chez un caviste
l'explication semble simple sur internet
on n'a pas besoin de beauty juste un
autre pot comme celui voiliers et des
bureaux
et voici comment ce site organise le
passage du virtuel au réel
les dégustations avec les clients dans
un grand hôtel parisien un moyen de les
rassurer et de les fidéliser ces gens là
sont très fidèles mais de façon plus
rationnelle
je peux vous confier que tous les
clients qui sont à ce soir comme une
cape 4 fois plus sur la même sélection
blanc le 24
quelques astuces permettent aussi de
faire de bonnes affaires ce site par
exemple offre à l'internaute une sorte
de carte de fidélité géante
chaque fois qu'ils effectuent un achat
chez l'un des quatre cent trente sites
partenaires
l'utilisateur récupère un pourcentage en
monnaies on est considérés comme des des
grossistes une centrale d'achat pour les
marchands qui sont demandeurs de ce
genre de solution qui cherche toujours à
acquérir des nouvelles ventes
mais attention ce clic de souris peut
parfois être trompeur vous voilà parti
pour stockholm pour seulement 10 euros
enfin presque puisque au moment de
confirmer votre commande la magie des
taxes d'aéroport et autres commissions a
multiplié par plus de trois le prix de
votre billet d'avion et ce n'est pas
tout nous voici chez ebay l'un des plus
gros vendeurs d'internet on y trouve de
tout mais vraiment de tout comme ses
cheveux de ramsès ii où ce tableau soit
disant signé du célèbre peintre vato des
enchères en ligne sans vérification
possible alors le conseil des ventes a
assigné le site en justice
il ya là dedans une quantité d'objets
contrefaits et quantité d'objets volés
nous sommes là pour protéger le
consommateur pour assurer la
transparence et la régularité des
opérations sur le marché pour éviter les
pièges
il suffit pourtant d'observer des règles
toutes simples comme savoir que ce
cadenas ou ce petit s signifie que le
paiement est sécurisé économie encore
ségolène royal était à romans dans la
drôme aujourd'hui à la rencontre des
ouvriers et des ouvrières d'une usine
charles jourdan mise en liquidation
judiciaire le président s'amuse et
pendant ce temps la france souffre avec
l'arrêt l'ex candidate elle a appelé à
la mise en place d'une politique
industrielle pour faire face je cite
encore à la cruauté sociale des
entreprises qui ferment et délocalisent
en bref encore 40 vols annulés et une
heure de retard en moyenne
une grève des personnels au sol d'air
france a provoqué des perturbations à
orly-ouest ici mais aussi à nice à
marseille à toulouse et nantes
aujourd'hui une grève pour les salaires
qui doit durer jusqu'à demain matin
et puis sachez que c'est frédéric
saint-geours directeur général de
peugeot qui va remplacer denis gautier
sauvagnac à la tête de lui et même la
fédération patronale de la métallurgie
l'audience est attendu attendu et
redouté c'est demain au tchad que
commence le procès des six français de
l'arche de zoé
tous les avocats sont arrivés sur place
le président de l'association eric
breteau évoque une mascarade judiciaire
amaury guibert frédéric rendent sur
place à n'djamena ces deux nouveaux
l'agitation devant la maison d'arrêt de
n'djamena
toute la journée les avocats français
des membres de l'arche de zoé ont fait
le point sur le dossier avec leurs
clients pour les convaincre surtout
d'assister au procès certains ont hésité
comme le confirme emilie lelouch dans ce
témoignage recueilli depuis sa scène
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a on voulait
ne pas y aller parce que veut pas
participer à cette parodie
aujourd'hui on a changé la vie on se dit
qu'il ya une tribune médiatique on va
s'en servir
on a envie d'expliquer aux journaux
point de vue que les gens nous juge sur
nos paroles et pas sur ce qu'on a dit
c'est évident que c'est une claque on va
se prendre va s'écrouler mais ça veut
pas dire qu'on remet en question ce
qu'on a fait pas de remise en question
une ligne de défense confirmée par les
avocats
vous savez qu elles sont venues pour une
opération humanitaire
- d'un traité en accord avec la mairie à
l'instant la partie pour elle ces souris
pour le médecin vous voyez des enfants
pour les autres le sort des orphelins
alors tout le reste est littérature mais
pour eux les conséquences de la sphère
sont bien concrète
ces six hommes ont tous confié un ou
plusieurs enfants à l'arche de zoé
c'est une délégation de père
représentant les 70 familles qui se sont
constitués partie civile le procès
distille servira à laver leur honneur
un enfant ne peut pas le prendre
n'importe quel moment tout l'or du monde
ne suffirait pas pour la voir le procès
doit durer au moins trois jours mais
pour la défense comme pour les parties
civiles l'issue semble déjà écrites dans
l'une de ses nombreuses déclarations
qu'il a faites depuis sa prison eric
breteau lui-même dit s'attendre à être
condamné mercredi prochain et rapatrié
en france avant la fin de l'année
bonsoir amaury guibert vous êtes en
direct à n'djamena n'oublions pas les
enfants où en est-on vont ils retrouver
leurs parents et bien à vide les 103
enfants qu'ils ont été confiés à l'arche
de zoé sont actuellement toujours
retenus à l'orphelinat d'abéché à l'est
du tchad un orphelinat qui porte
aujourd'hui bien mal son nom
les autorités tchadiennes les
organisations internationales qui ont
traité ce dossier en sont aujourd'hui
certaines la quasi-totalité même tous
ces enfants sont un père et une mère
aucun est orphelin de père et de mère
les enquêtes de terrain mais aussi les
entretiens avec les familles ont permis
de livrer une deuxième information
quasiment tous les enfants à quelques
exceptions près vienne le village
tchadien située près de la frontière
avec le soudan et le darfour
la prochaine étape c'est maintenant la
réunification selon le terme de l'unicef
c'est à dire les retrouvailles entre les
enfants et leurs familles c'est imminent
tout dépend en fait d'une décision de la
justice tchadienne qui devrait
intervenir vraisemblablement peu de
temps après le procès qui s'ouvre ici
demain à n'djamena merci a mûri en ce
qui concerne les membres de l'arche de
zoé rappelons qu'il ya une convention
entre paris n'djamena en cas de
condamnation il pourrait donc purger
tout ou partie de leur peine en france
c'est bien sûr ce que souhaitent leurs
familles qui n'ont pas perdu l'espoir
non plus d'un non lieu on écoute les
pousses du médecin de l'arche de zoé
évidemment la première des choses que je
souhaite c'est
c'est qu'il revienne parce que c'est
c'est l'homme de ma vie c'est l'homme
que j'ai mon seul qui reviennent mais
s'il pouvait revenir avec un non lieu
ça serait serait que justice parce qu'il
est innocent il est parti pour sonner il
est parti pour soigner des enfants il
est parti pour soigner tous les gens
besoins en souffrance ont dû faire
depuis quand soigner est un crime
j'aimerais faire confiance à la justice
italienne
propos recueillis par yannick à rossi on
reste sur le continent africain avec
cette page qui est sans doute en train
de se tourner après nelson mandela après
thabo mbeki le très controversé jacob
zuma
idole de l'ethnie zoulou et les
quartiers populaires pourrait devenir
prochainement le troisième président de
l'afrique du sud multiraciale
jacob zuma 65 ans ou en taxer de
populistes et qui a fait l'objet
d'accusations de corruption a été élu à
la tête de la haine c'est le parti au
pouvoir ce qui le met en situation
idéale
et ce alors que le rêve d'une nation
arc-en-ciel connaît de sérieux ratés
il faut savoir qu'un millions de sud
africains blancs ont quitté le pays
depuis la fin de l'apartheid il ya 13
ans principal motif de ce départ la
criminalité l'autodéfense là bas est
devenue la règle
voyez le reportage étonnant de nos
envoyés spéciaux dominique derda et
frédéric guiraud la première fois
qu'elle a tenu un pistolet dans ses
mains il ya quelques mois
angélique ne savait pas trop par quel de
l'europe depuis en croire son
instructeur elle a fait des progrès même
si elle n'est pas encore très à l'aise
angelica 11 ce matin ils sont une
trentaine sur le pâtir des sud africains
qui comme angélique et ses parents
vivent en permanence dans la peur de
l'agression
why ayoun pourquoi tu apprends à tirer
tu crois que ça pourrait servir à ça
c'est pour me défendre je crois qu'on
peut faire confiance à personne
n'importe qui peut attaquer la plupart
des participants à ce stage
d'autodéfense sont des fermiers mais pas
tous la famille vende copenhagen vient
de pretoria où le père d'angélique
travaille dans l'informatique au
printemps les gardiens de son entreprise
ont été assommés et ligoté par des
voleurs lui s'en est tiré de justesse un
peu depuis cet incident il ya six mois
je suis armé ans
permanence où que j'aille je porte un
pistolet à la cheville ni la police
frappe à ma porte
il veut entrer chez moi je me méfie je
demande à tous mes voeux si les avec ma
voiture au bord de la route j'ai très
peur qu'il s'en prenne à moi y vivent
est risqué depuis l'instauration de
cette soi disant démocratie dit ce
responsable du syndicat des agriculteurs
2300 fermiers au moins ont été tuées
chacun ici qu'on est un proche un ami un
voisin qui a été abattu chez lui ou sur
ses terres la criminalité le problème
numéro un en afrique du sud et les
blancs parce qu'ils sont les anciens
maîtres du pays vont se sentent
directement visé freedom ring et le
monsieur sécurité du syndicat agricole
un ancien colonel de l'armée sud
africaine de l'apartheid il dit
regretter l'ordre qui régnait à l'époque
par le régime sous l'ancien gouvernement
au moins il y avait des gens capables de
protéger les honnêtes citoyens
je ne peux pas dire la même chose du
gouvernement actuel la police est
tellement inefficace on ne peut pas
compter sur elle
c'est juste une question de compétence
au deuxième jour du stage
angélique apprend à tirer au fusil
d'assaut
c'est le clou du week-end le moment que
chacun attendait surtout avec la
kalachnikov en bref encore à l'étranger
la paix est théoriquement en route mais
les affrontements continuent au
proche-orient nouvelle opération
israélienne à gaza contre des activistes
palestiniens suite à des tirs de
roquettes cinq d'entre eux ont été tués
aujourd'hui dans le territoire en europe
une petite révolution en cours à
amsterdam
le maire de la ville a lancé à un projet
d'assainissement du célèbre quartier
rouge dans lequel vous le savez les
femmes s'affichent dans des vitrines et
se prostitue
c'est l'une des images d'epinal de la
ville mais beaucoup jugent bien
évidemment la pratique très choquant
envoyés spéciaux zine dine boudaoud à
belz wiiware
la nuit à amsterdam les canaux
romantique se transforme la prostitution
s'affiche sous toutes ses formes
mais pour la ville ces images lui called
un peu trop à la peau au point de
vouloir leur disparition
les clients eux ne comprennent pas
pourquoi moi j'aime les filles dans les
vitrines
c'est plus ouvert plus direct c'est bien
connu
ces lieux là il y a moins de criminalité
le quartier rouge comme le surnomme est
dans le collimateur de la mairie à la
place des prostituées des coffee shops
le maire verrait bien des boutiques de
luxe et les restaurants haut de gamme
depuis 30 ans richie gagne sa vie grâce
à son sex-shop
il emploie 5 personnes le projet du
maire laurent malades et des états unis
ou de suède et que vous n'avez pas
visité le quartier rouge alors vous
n'avez pas visité amsterdam et c'est ce
business que ce mr stupide veut tuer la
mairie d'amsterdam veut fermer la
totalité des 400 vitrine de prostitution
pour lutter contre les réseaux mafieux
malheureusement il y à de nombreuses
organisations criminelles qui exploitent
ces femmes qui se serrent vedette est de
ceux là
nous n'en voulons plus du tout cet ex
belle de nuit se bat contre le projet
aux pays-bas les filles peuvent cotiser
payer leurs impôts mais il joue bach
s'inquiète pour celles qui sont menacées
si toutes les vitrines ferme 400 fille
perdront leur travail
ce vont-elles devenir la question ne se
pose pas seulement pour celles qui sont
sous la coupe des criminels mais aussi
celles qui sont à leur coûtent chaque
année amsterdam reçoit la visite de plus
de 3 millions de touristes le quartier
rouge et ses filles sont incontournables
et pour montrer kamsar dames il n'y a
pas loin de la parole aux actes la ville
annoncera la mi janvier la fermeture
définitive de plus de 50 vitrine de
prostitution un coup de force
retentissant s'il a vraiment lieu est
sans doute le début d'une longue
bataille judiciaire
retour en france avec le procès du
carambolage de l'adisq qui avait fait
neuf morts il ya cinq ans les dix
conducteurs impliqués ont été condamnés
à des peines de prison à vie
sursis un jugement qui n'est pas du tout
compris par les familles des victimes
anne guillet paix fabien tormos cinq ans
après avoir perdu son père et sa mère
dans le carambolage
chantal barreto va enfin pouvoir tourner
une page mais à la lecture du jugement
elle craque
seulement trois mois de prison avec
sursis et des amendes minime pour les
automobilistes impliqués et surtout
aucun prévenu n'est présent serait peu
rugueux pour tous qui est ce on le sait
mais wiki qu'ils nous disent
excusez-nous site c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'on attend des comptes où il semble
ici t'es même pas présents même pas
présent 5 novembre 2002 un carambolage
en chaîne se produit sur l'autoroute a10
au sud de poitiers 58 véhicules sont
impliqués dans dix camions le bilan est
très lourd neuf morts et une quarantaine
de blessés
en cause la vitesse excessive mais
surtout un brouillard très dense
ça veut dire que le tribunal a tenu
compte des circonstances exceptionnelles
et cet accident
et de ce point de vue là le résultat est
satisfaisant prenant les pilotes d'un
procès qui se voulait surtout
pédagogique
cinq ans après les condamnés pourront
conserver leur permis de conduire
et puis suite à l'accident du tgv paris
genève hier on apprend que trois
personnes ont été placées en garde à vue
elles appartiennent à l'entreprise de
transports dont dépendent est le camion
qui n'aurait pas dû emprunter cette
route
en bref encore deux attentats en corse à
ajaccio à dix minutes d'intervalle la
nuit dernière ils ont fait un blessé
léger et de gros dégâts
l'un à la préfecture de région l'autre à
la direction l'équipement le tout une
semaine après la fin du procès d' yvan
colonna pas de revendication pour
l'instant toujours en corse le tribunal
administratif de bastia a rejeté
finalement la plainte de deux malades
atteints d'un cancer de la thyroïde de
malades qui pointe du doigt ce qu'ils
dénomment un mensonge d'état pour la
maladie serait directement liée au
passage du nuage de tchernobyl au dessus
de l'île il y à 21 ans
reportage nathalie sapina sylvain
gauthier
c'est sous le soleil de bastia que
charles lacourarie a grandi sans souci
notable jusqu'à ses 24 ans on lui
découvre alors un cancer rare de la
thyroïde côté donc d'une oreille à
l'autre
c'était très dur à vivre et c'est
toujours dur à vivre aux gens dont je
suis condamné contre rieumes et à
prendre des médicaments à vie et je suis
bi
une fois par an des
contrôles médicaux toujours sur paris
donc toujours quelques semaines avant
cette angoisse d'autant plus dure à
supporter qu'il en est convaincu la
cause de son cancer c'est le nuage de
tchernobyl qui a survolé la corse en
1986 et contaminer les légumes et les
produits laitiers qu'il a mangé à
l'époque il avait 9 ans l'état français
n'a pas interdit la consommation de ces
produits qui concentrent la
radioactivité
on nous a rien dit on nous a caché la
vérité quand ce nuage et a traversé
l'europe pour nous a dit que en france
il n'y avait rien alors que dans
d'autres pays européens des précautions
dès des prises le tribunal a rejeté sa
requête
mais il va faire appel contre l'état
avec les mêmes arguments
si vous aviez dit la vérité je serais
allé à la pharmacie prendre des cachets
diodes j'aurais éviter de manger du lait
de boire du lait de manger de la viande
d'aller chercher des champignons d'aller
dans la garrigue et toutes ces
précautions sont que peut-être j'aurais
aujourd'hui une situation au niveau de
la santé une situation saine alors y at
il plus de cancers de la thyroïde en
corse
aucune étude ne démontre mais pour les
médecins corse il n'y a pas de doute il
soigne plus de maladies de la thyroïde
même non cancéreuses la demande est très
forte de consultation pour ce type de
pathologie
c'est de l'ordre de 60% alors qu'à un
cabinet d'endocrinologie normal enfin
normal je dirais habituel représente à
une activité d'environ
trente pour cent vingt-et-un ans après
le nuage de tchernobyl n'en finit pas
d'inquiéter
plusieurs études sont actuellement
lancés en corse d'autant qu'une plainte
au pénal déposée par six ans victime de
toute la france en 2001 est toujours en
cours d'instruction
en bref un retable a été restitué à une
commune du val d'oise aujourd'hui voler
dans l'église de vétheuil il y a trente
ans il a été retrouvé chez un antiquaire
belge qui l'avait lui-même acheté l'an
passé à cette occasion la ministre de la
culture christine albanel albanel a
annoncé des mesures contre le vol dans
les églises des vols qui se multiplient
ces derniers mois
l'image signé philippe jasselin la
perception religieuse de la fête de noël
est très minoritaire c'est ce qu'indique
un sondage tns sofres pour
l'hebdomadaire pèlerin 27% des personnes
interrogées l'évoquent pour la grande
majorité c'est une affaire de famille à
quelques jours de ce 25 décembre nous
avons voulu savoir ce que signifiait
devenir séminaristes aujourd'hui
regarder la courbe leur nombre diminue
régulièrement depuis dix ans même s'il
s'est stabilisée ces dernières années
alors à quoi répond l'engagement en
religion pour un jeune en 2007
reportage françois jullien pied noir
frédéric
loin de la fureur des grands magasins et
de la fièvre acheteuse
onze jeunes séminaristes futurs prêtres
en normandie répète pour la messe de
noël
pas le temps de faire les cadeaux jan à
26 ans étudie et pris 7 jours sur 7
et pour noël il va faire la fête à sa
façon les chrétiens dans ma paroisse de
noël ian est entré au séminaire à l'âge
de 18 ans ses parents ne sont pas
pratiquants et pourtant il a eu un appel
de dieu
un coup de foudre quand on tombe
amoureux
on sait pas pourquoi on est forcément
amoureux de cette personne l'armée mais
on l'est et c'est très fort eh bien nous
c'est pareil on est on est vraiment
amoureux de l'église du christ et on a
envie de donner toute la vie pour pour
donner l'amour de dieu aux hommes avec
tout ce que ça engage avec tout ce que
ça engage comme chaque soir ils dînent
tous entre frères mais ne leur dites
surtout pas qu'ils vivent de manière
austère on n'est plus au xviiie siècle
comme ils disent et bercée par la
culture contemporaine que ce soit le
cinéma c'est juste comme ça donc on
n'est pas complètement déconnecté de la
réalité du quotidien du jeune de notre
hcg pas car perdre à cette voie là moi
je crois que la joie fait partie
chrétienne mais ce qui les attriste le
plus en ce moment c'est que noël a perdu
de son sens noyés par le champagne et le
flot des achats
c'est justement pas sur une orgie
l'importance et c'est faire la fête
ensemble
mais pas que ça devienne les marques
principales de la fête d'enfer 204 ça
c'est exactement ça ce poète inflexion
slogan s'ils ne changent pas d'avis dans
un an et demi yann sera ordonné prêtre
c'est lui qui alors dans sa paroisse
célèbrera noël une fête uniquement
religieuses à ses yeux
noëlie côté matérialisme maintenant avec
le cadeau le plus demandé où le plus
offert cette année il s'agit des
cartes-cadeaux elles se vendent par
millions en ce moment avantage bien sûr
laisser le choix à la personne qui la
reçoit
c'est aussi plus convivial que l'argent
liquide roma mais si lionel langlade un
bout de plastique qui tient dans la
poche et dans la main la carte cadeau
séduit un large public
la personne qui la reçoit s'achète
ensuite ce qu'elle veut en un mot
pratique
sur deux ports se compter
ça leur laisse le libre choix du cd et
du dvd jeux quand on sait pas quoi
choisir toujours une bonne idée des
cartes prépayées jusqu'à 150 euros en
guise de cadeau
mais alors pourquoi ne pas offrir tout
simplement de l'argent
stepan même gène c'est pas pareil argent
ou carte tous deux sur le podium des
cadeaux les plus souhaités par les
français pour noël
plus festif qu'un billet de banque
souvent multi enseignes la carte cadeau
fait un tabac l'année dernière nous
avons vendu à peu près 3 millions de
cartes et un magasin comme celui ci est
en progression pratiquement de 20% par
rapport à l'an dernier
un succès qui a donné des idées à
d'autres
c'est une carte bancaire le principe
c'est l'offrir à quelqu'un une carte
bancaire qu'on appelle le prépayé
donc vous allez déterminer le montant
que vous allez offrir dessus la personne
à qui vous l'offrez pas pouvoir
l'utiliser dans tous les magasins sans
bien sûr dépenser plus que ce qui a été
offert la carte a séduit plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes l'an
dernier
un cadeau sans risque quand on sait
qu'un français sur trois se dit déçue
parce qu'ils trouvent au pied du sapin
la mort de l'éditeur christian bourgois
il avait fondé sa propre maison en 1966
et publié entre autres les versets
sataniques de salman rushdie en france
il avait 74 ans du cirque avec alexis
gruss c'est la saison alexis gruss et
son nouveau spectacle orchestra trois
générations se mêlent sur la piste les
anciens apprennent les numéros plus
jeunes autour d'une soixantaine de
chevaux qui sont à l'origine de la
renommée de grue ce set à paris jusqu'au
9 mars prochain marie-hélène bono
guillaume michel
oh
les gruss une véritable dynastie le père
la mère de garçons une fille trois
petits-fils tous enfant de la balle
c'est sa plus belle récompense
la transmission c'est quand même
l'essence même de la vie sa part des
racines et si vous faites pérenniser les
racines verser libyen les racines c'est
lui à 60 ans passés alexis gruss est
presque toujours sur la piste il a
transmis à mort de sa fille la passion
de l'équitation mais pas seulement
elle pratique d'autres disciplines va
nous rattraper et un numéro des hautes
écoles et que mes parents donc ses
séjours en famille
les enfants gruss ici le fils firme avec
sa femme ont tout appris sous le
chapiteau familiale
et vous n'êtes pas fait d'école l'école
de cirque je crois qu'ici on est dans la
meilleure école de cirque au monde le
petit fils louis à ses débuts pas si
lointain il avait un peu le trac
la première fois numéro oui mais on
s'habitue vite
une vie d'enfant pas ordinaire votre
répétition mais aussi école avec ses
frères ce n'est pas parce qu'on
s'appelle gruss qu'on vous force à être
artiste de cirque avec ma femme on tient
à ce qu'ils aillent à l'école qui
justement choisir
alexis gruss a repris le rôle de son
père celui du clown blanc
sa vie c'est maintenir la tradition d'un
cirque à l'ancienne où la tendresse et
l'émotion sont plus importantes que la
performance avant de refermer cette
édition vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres jean paul bolufer
directeur de cabinet de christine boutin
a remis sa démission ce matin hier la
presse avait révélé qu'il bénéficiait
d'un logement public à bas prix jean
paul bolufer demande précisément une
remise à plat du système
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo nathalie rihouet
point route nouvelle formule avec
valérie maurice 20h50 envoyé spécial ce
week-end vous retrouverez laurent
delahousse puis françoise laborde à
partir de lundi soir je vous souhaite de
très bonnes fêtes à tous
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr autre soirée sur